los ejércitos de Corea del Sur y Estados
Unidos dispararon hoy 4 misiles de corto
alcance tierra Tierra al mar de Japón en
respuesta al lanzamiento realizado el
martes por Corea del Norte El martes
pyongyang disparó un misil balístico de
alcance intermedio que por primera vez
en cinco años sobrevoló territorio
japonés y que además es el proyectil
norcoreano que más distancia ha cubierto
jamás al volar en torno a
4.500 kilómetros esta respuesta
combinada de los aliados que hemos visto
hoy pueden marcarse dentro de lo que sea
dado en Llamar la disuasión ampliada que
es un compromiso alcanzado por parte de
Washington con seúl y que puede implicar
el despliegue de activos estratégicos
estadounidenses en la Península en
función de las acciones de Corea del
Norte según muchos expertos esto puede
implicar que sobre todo si Corea del
Norte va a seguir haciendo ensayos de
armas en las próximas semanas y si opta
por probar misiles de mayor Rango Aún es
posible que veamos como en años
anteriores despliegue en la Península de
cazabombarderos estadounidenses furtivos
b2 a su vez en muchos analistas creen
que esta prueba
norcoreana del martes puede situar en el
Horizonte un nuevo test nuclear por
parte de pyongyang recordemos que los
satélites han captado que desde hace
meses el ejército norcoreano está listo
para llevar a cabo un nuevo test atómico
sin embargo en muchos creen que esta
prueba tendría lugar en todo caso
después de la celebración del congreso
del partido comunista chino de Cara a no
solviantar a su principal Aliado en la
región